if someone comes to you and says hey i
have this great script that i wrote
how do i get a studio to make it i just
adam please can you just get this i know
you work in hollywood or you know people
in hollywood
can i get this script to you
um like what do i say i mean it depends
it's situational too i mean i'm you know
it depends i mean it depends on the
conversation depends on you know what
type of movie it is and everything else
i mean
i read a lot but um
beyond that i mean if you're asking me
uh
when when filmmakers come to me and
they're like oh how do i get this made
i i need hollywood to make it like yes
they see it it's going to be the next
fill in the blank this almost always
comes with them attached to play the
lead
um in which case since that is most
cases
i usually say i think you should
consider
finding a way to go make your film and
make it on your terms
um it's just not 1978
anymore i mean i wish it was but it's
not
and um the days of sitting and
coffee being chewing your nails waiting
on a deal is not
realistic you know it's just not going
to happen that way
so i would say like you know try if you
can get any traction that way terrific
but look at what's out there and look
you when you know if that person is
saying i wanted
like a studio to make my film for 40 50
million dollars i want to be in theaters
say look what's in theaters though is
anything
is there anything like what you're doing
right now and
that's not to discourage people from
making the film but i would say like
find a way to go make it your way
because they're going to try and take it
away from you anyway and they're going
to you know
have weird ideas and you know take it in
their own direction but
that's my advice like i think we're just
living in an era where
you just have to go do it and it's
[ __ ] easier than ever
i mean look at look at cassavetes and
look at all the great he's the
he's the bar and he's who we always
refer to as like the person who went out
and did it
and he shot on film and they had lab
fees
and we don't have that i mean we we can
have that but we
we also have the alexas and the reds and
this technology where we can go shoot
now so there's just no excuse
what if they say i'm not in hollywood
i'm in
a state that there's no industry here
dude even better everyone's going to
want to help you
i mean seriously everyone's going to
want to help you everyone's going to be
not everyone but you know people are
going to want to help in the community
because
they want to help you succeed they've
never seen a film done before
it's interesting it's novel um
i found it much easier to shoot outside
of la
you know here it's like i went to i went
to astro burger
the one next to paramount because i had
a scene and an aster burger
and i went in the morning and i talked
to the guy and
he was the guy and i'm like bare bones
indie film i would need like three hours
i could come during off hours no problem
even night is fine i can fake it for day
he's like yeah 20 000. i'm like
copy that it's where you are
you know it's just that there are people
who will pay that and and
you know that is a thing so i think if
you're living outside of la it's a
benefit
and you can you can get a lot more
mileage out of whatever you're doing
and you shot restraint where
uh predominantly in apple valley is that
san bernardino county
i think so no high desert okay
and that was like that too i mean that
we we found that to be the case we had
you know our producer was from there so
we had certain
resources but um
you know that not withstanding it was um
[Music]
it was a very inexpensive permit and
they were very open to a shooting
you know throughout the city in
different areas gas stations cleaners
parks things like that and they're just
very helpful
who did you contact to get that permit
did did they have a film office
yeah you know the producer did that but
um it was i think we got it out of
necessity i think we were shooting and
then
um we were shooting in a house and then
one of the
uh the policemen stopped by and
was like do you guys have a permit like
we need it for the house he's like yeah
he's like you can
keep going don't worry about it but you
need to get that i was like wow here
they'd shut you down
they just take your memory card and you
know make an example out of you but
you know you go one hour outside of la
and they're just
ultra helpful
you